now to the Democratic Republic of Congo
it's home to mines containing some of
the purest gold in the world but while
consumers in richer countries are
prepared to pay high prices for a
finished product The Men Who mine this
precious commodity are paying a price of
a different kind extortion and rights
abuses are Rife at the DRC gold mines
which are controlled by a brutal Rebel
group
access to foreign journalists has been
restricted until now but a joint
investigation with the German news
weekly Dash beagle has resulted in DW's
Mario Muller being allowed to enter two
rebel-controlled gold mines and speak to
minors themselves
this gold May gleam brightly but it is
stained red with blood people likely
died for this precious metal destined
for the rich world's finest jewelries
the Democratic Republic of the Congo has
some of the purest gold in the world but
experts say almost all of it smuggled
out of the country illegally that often
means links to Armed groups and human
rights abuses
it all starts here in suffocatingly hot
tunnels that hit up to 40 degrees
Celsius
young men scrape out the gold-bearing
Rock
they earn barely enough to survive on
for fear of reprisals this man wants to
remain anonymous
when you go to work you just pray to God
because we're feeling like it's a death
sentence
often it is when the minds cave in six
years ago more than 20 people were
buried alive
I was there with my three brothers and
other miners all of them were trapped
inside the mine
even now their bodies are still inside I
was sad really down but I can't be sad
for long I have to earn a living
and on top of that this mine is
controlled by an armed group the maima
yakutumba according to a recent un
report the rebels demand what they call
taxes from each worker they beat me up
with an iron Rod because I couldn't pay
their tax they threw me into a mud hole
for days with no food I was imprisoned
there with six other people
he lost 10 kilograms he says other
miners tell us similar stories they say
the maimai are never far even now
they're hiding further up the mountain
because they were informed we were
coming
this is the first time journalists have
accessed this mine
both the maima yakutumba and local
government officials declined our
interview requests it's widely known
that the rebels often work together with
local authorities and even share profits
with them
but with the money they also Finance
brutal attacks on an ethnic group who
they see as their main enemy the maimai
claim the Banya mulenge don't belong to
the DRC so they burn down their Villages
rape and kill scores of people
survived one of these attacks
they found us at the place where we had
sought refuge and they killed three
people
then they murdered my father-in-law and
injured my mother-in-law
me both of them were over 80 she says
she and her family were forced to March
for days with no food then they took her
husband she never saw him again later
she learned he was hacked to death with
a machete
they killed dozens displaced hundreds
now is that safe Sheltering at a
friend's house
Rebel control of the mines means
conflict gold but that's not deterring
this businessman the purity of the
precious metal has convinced him soon he
plans to open the first gold refinery in
the country and export from DRC to
Europe and America at the moment we're
discussing a lot with the government
they will check all Artisans who are
coming to work here we will they will
try and Trace how is going on and maybe
it will help I hope it will help but
ensuring authenticity will be difficult
Traders tell us they fake certificates
to hide the real origin of the gold
Eastern and Uhura can only appeal for an
end to the trade in blood gold
I hear the my my cell go to white people
to buy weapons that's why they sell the
gold
I want to tell these white people to
stop buying from them so they don't kill
us with these weapons
for Easter it is a simple equation as
long as armed groups can read profits
from gold mining they will keep earning
the cash to kill
foreign
he's an expert on Central Africa and
recently published a book about the role
minerals play in conflicts in the
Democratic Republic of Congo he joins us
from Brussels thanks for being with us
first of all Christophe uh the mind we
saw in that report it's one of many in
the DRC the country has Rich reserves of
minerals yet it's people remain among
the poorest in the world can you explain
that discrepancy for us
yeah hello um there is well there's
probably two things to say um on a
broader um scale the first one being
um indeed um the Congo is like rich in
minerals and produces a lot of um very
important minerals however
um the link between um those artisanal
mines and poverty is a bit uh mistaken
because
um the industrial mines were um
especially copper and Cobalt are sourced
in other parts of the country and where
there has been a lot of corruption
involving International companies in the
past decades are actually sort of the
main economic engine of the country that
would need sort of a reform to actually
benefit the people and fight poverty on
a larger scale and the second thing is
um if you look at the Eastern Congo
where you have a lot of armed conflicts
going on it is true that the story that
we just heard about the mayakutumba is
one of the clear cases where there is
um control for the sake of my training
by armed groups however out of the of
some 120 armed groups that are currently
operating in eastern Congo that is
pretty much an outlier case um where we
see today that there is only a minority
of armed groups that are actually
operating um with the um main objective
to secure mining areas okay so it's
important to keep an eye on the
commercial aspect of minerals extraction
in the DRC as well tell us why
authorities in the DRC have not tackled
the illegal mining of gold
well for a number of reasons I mean the
first reason sort of was implied in my
answer uh in my previous answer is that
in the end
um the artisanal mining of gold but also
other substance substances such as
Colton does not represent a very
important share of Congo's economy um so
there is a limited attention as compared
to other sectors such as copper and
Cobalt were industrial mining is um is
way more important that than um than the
gold being exported from Congo the
second reason is that um the threshold
of what is legal and illegal is often
not very clear so you had um sort of
Contraband and fraud in Gold especially
to neighboring countries such as Uganda
has a very long story and is often not
perceived necessarily as an illegal
thing and that has predated armed
conflict and will probably also extend
uh if ever armed conflict will end in
that region
now there are international efforts to
regulate unethical mining in the DRC and
elsewhere how successful are those
efforts
well there have been efforts in um in
other minerals especially Colton tin and
and tungsten
um that um
broadly failed because they didn't the
United brought an ends to um to Armed
activities in the region nor could they
actually give a reasonable Assurance in
the case of gold it's a little bit more
complicated because there's a number of
pilot projects to to trace the origin of
of so-called conflict gold but the the
chemical composition of gold
um which is unique as in that it is
exactly identical
um from a geochemical point of view
makes it harder to to trace gold to its
origin and the um the value for um for
weight which is much higher in Gold than
in most other minerals also makes it
much easier to hide in in small
quantities that can then be brought
together again into bigger quantities in
in major hubs such as Dubai or or places
in Europe and also okay Crystal thank
you very much I'm afraid we're out of
time there uh that was uh that was
author and researcher Christoph Fogel
thank you